there's y equals x squared as simple as
it gets right
we're going to do a rotation of this
thing around
well part a is the x-axis so that's well
that's what you would have done in
low levels of mass but then they say
okay now do it around the line y
uh sorry x equals one so let's draw that
in and see how this fits
okay
so if i make that x equals one and if
you have something comfortable there
right you can see that it's the area
bounded by the curve
there the x-axis there
and the line x equals one so here's the
area
that they're going to form a solid out
of by a rotation
okay now they're rotating it around this
axis
x equals one is the axis right so here
you go
that's the kind of rotation we got so
what kind of shape are we going to get
well let's see something like this
symmetrical around here
and
there you go there's my shape kind of a
pointy looking cone there right
now that's not too hard let's think
about how we approach this
by thinking about the annulus that we
get when we slice this perpendicular to
the axis because that's the way slices
works right
i'll draw it down here the slices we can
get
something like this
there you go now there's actually no
hole in there so as an annulus
i just draw that in there to indicate
well that's the center okay but i don't
need to think about a big radius and a
little radius anymore which is nice
and simple but there's still some traps
in there okay now it's an annular disc
so it really should have some a tiny bit
of width there
okay so how am i going to deal with this
thing this is y equals x squared
right so i'm thinking about this area
under here so
i want to know well usually i think
about a big radius a little radius
but i just want a big radius it's here
isn't it
that there okay so i want to know what
is that radius
in terms of of this function here okay
so how can we approach this don't forget
because we are rotating around the
vertical axis so it's a little bit line
rotating around the y axis right
you're not going to rotate x squared i u
okay because that would go around this
axis sorry this axis
right um instead of x squared what are
we going to rotate any suggestions
what what would you call this
if you're looking at it sideways
hmm you look at this thing sideways
right
it looks a little bit like the square
root of wine doesn't it
looks like a good candidate that's how
the that's how the square of y grows
doesn't it okay
is that the radius of our angular disk
who reckons it is any takers
it's a shame one of the people who ask
me this question isn't here
because this is what you get and it's
it's a fairly common sense way to
approach it right
the problem is excuse me this here
is not the square root of y the square
root of y is this distance
okay it's the distance from the curve to
the axis
okay but we don't want that distance
that's not the area that's being rotated
what is the area
it's the part to the right isn't it well
i guess it'd be something like that
okay that's the radius or or that's the
radius or that
you get the idea okay so if it's not the
square root of y
what is it it's one minus isn't it
because that that whole disc is there
if that's x equals one that whole
distance is one
right so if this distance here is the
square root of y then i want to take the
difference
okay so therefore the big radius of the
annulus that i'm gonna um add up right
is actually
one minus that okay now
i sort of glossed over this before but
it is helpful to um sort of distinguish
this
um doing volumes by slicing from the
regular integration that you've learned
in two unit three unit okay
what we'll do is write it out as
our proper sigma notation because that's
really what we're doing
we're adding up a whole bunch of slices
okay sorry
what are these slices what am i adding
on
i'm adding up a whole bunch of slices
from now where are my boundaries
okay i'm thinking about this going
upwards okay i've got a whole bunch of
slices like this
okay in fact you can see them sort of
like that okay so i'm going from
y equals zero to y equals one can you
see that
i guess it's just a coincidence that
your x boundaries are the same
okay
take a seat now
that's where i'm adding them up okay but
what are the actual things i'm adding up
this thing here right this annulus it'll
be um
well let's see it'll be pi r squared
h wouldn't it like that's just a
cylinder and then you'd subtract it here
but the thing is i don't have a
inside radius so i just have this
okay but a couple of changes we need to
make right
i actually know what r is we've defined
it here okay does that make sense
so really instead of capital r i should
be writing
one minus the square root of y
squared okay there's my radius okay
the second thing is instead of h i
shouldn't be writing
h what am i considering what is the
height
of my disc okay so
now if you write in a few different ways
um really the best way that we should
write it is
delta y okay delta y is an actual length
it's comparable to h i suppose when
you're doing first principles okay
so delta y from which
d y gets its name and i want to think
about this thing
as the slices get thinner and thinner
and thinner okay in other words
the limit as those slices tend towards
zero
okay now all this is this is sort of
like your prelude to what integration is
right
this idea of taking a number of slices
that are infinitesimally equal that's
what integration is
but we're writing this to show that i
know what i'm adding up it's these
angular disk things here
now being that these pieces one
two and three okay they're
what define integration okay this next
line i can write an integral
i'll take that pi out the front because
it's just constant don't worry about it
and now i can form my integral okay from
naught
to one of this guy
and now since i'm considering this this
process has changed now
it's not just adding up a whole bunch of
things i'm doing an algebraic
process namely integration okay that's
the transition from delta y to d y
okay and that's just an integral we can
deal with this
can't we let's do it pi out the front
not to one
what do you get when you expand
one minus i'll write that as rather than
uh
square root of y i'll write that with a
power because i'm going to integrate
plus y good with respect to y
okay let's integrate
okay one turns into a y what's this guy
become
power goes up to three on two and then
you divide by a new power
so i think it's going to be four on
three is that right yeah and you can
check that out
by multiplying back and differentiating
right that three the threes will cancel
that four over two cool it works good
plus
y squared on two from not to once
okay now as you can see because all of
your terms here have
y's in them you know that your lower
bound is just going to go to zero that's
nice okay and then what's gonna happen
here i'll get one
minus four thirds plus a half
and there's my lower bound okay uh
what's this guy
well that's that's negative third
so it's a half minus a third which i
think is a sixth
that's convenient isn't it okay but
there you go and um don't forget this is
a volume so it's um
units there you go all right
so really i think the beginner's trap is
in not being careful about how you
define
the radius of your of the annulus okay
once you've got that the rest of it just
falls out and you do want to um i mean
this notation this kind of thing this is
what makes it sort of volumes by slices
right it's more than just an algebraic
process integration
it's i know what's going on i'm adding
up a whole bunch of these okay
is anyone asking questions about that
people who just came in maybe i'll give
you a second to catch up and write that
all down
but like i said very simple question
right and
finishly difficult if you don't really
know what's going on